Hello world,
it's Saroj and there's some serious hyper
lately about this Ai Algorithm called
deep fakes that's able to swap the face
of anyone in a video with anybody else.
Some of the examples I've
seen are amazingly realistic.
I'm going to explain how this algorithm
works through theory and code and then
talk a bit about the moral
implications of this.
At the end of the video last month,
a redditor by the name of deep fakes of
course was making a name for himself by
posting, convincing, let's say,
not safe for work videos that swapped
the face of the person in the original
video with a famous celebrity
like say Taylor Swift.
He did this by training his deep learning
algorithm on some publicly available
videos with just his home computer
and in the past few weeks,
the practice of doing this has exploded.
There's now an entire subreddit and get
hub community dedicated to maintaining
this and sharing the
results of this algorithm.
The subreddit grew massively in size and
there's even this desktop application
called fake app that lets anyone recreate
one of these videos with their own
dataset. No knowledge of programming
necessary because of this.
People are putting Nicholas Cage's face
on literally everything and making a
meme out of it because it's the internet.
So how does the deep fake algorithm work?
Let's say we've got this video of Harrison
Ford in Indiana Jones and we want to
replace his face with Nicholas Cage
because why the hell not our first step is
going to be to gather some training data,
specifically images of both Harrison
Ford and Nicholas cage to later train our
models on possible sources of these
images. Could include Google duck, duck,
go or being image search.
Luckily the face swap repository has
scripts to automatically download large
amounts of images from one of these
sources to our home directory.
Once we've got a couple hundred images,
we can place them each in
their respective folder.
Notice though that these images are full
of stuff not related to our characters.
There are all sorts of objects and
distractions in the environments of these
images that have nothing
to do with our characters.
We're going to want to perform some
face detection on each of these images.
Pretty much all cameras that have been
created in the past decade have some sort
of real time based detection algorithm.
The open computer vision or open CV
library will allow us to easily recognize
faces in images.
We just a function call,
but the way it's doing this in the
background is by using a method called
histogram of oriented
gradients or hog for short.
It starts by making our image
black and white. To simplify it,
we don't need color data to find faces.
Then it looks at every single pixel
in the image on one at a time.
For every pixel it looks at the
pixels directly surrounding it.
The goal is to figure out how dark the
current Pixel is compared to the pixels
directly surrounding it.
Then it draws an arrow showing in which
direction the image is getting darker.
Once it does this process for
every single pixel in the image,
we'll end up with every pixel
being replaced by an arrow.
These arrows show the flow from light
to dark across the entire image.
If we analyze pixels directly,
then really dark images and really light
images of the same person would have
totally different pixel values.
But because we're only considering
the direction that brightness changes,
both types of images end up
with the same representation.
Making the problem easier to solve.
Saving all these directions
is to space intensive,
so we break the image into smaller
squares and count how many different
directions there are.
Then replace each square with the
direction that has the most counts.
This turns the original image into a
very simple representation that captures
the basic structure of
a face in a simple way.
Once open CV has a representation,
it can compare it by a distance metric
to another hog face pattern generated
from lots of face images and if it's
close to it by some threshold value,
we can consider the face the tech to once
we've got our face detected using open
CV,
we can just crop the original image so
it's just the face and save that instead.
Soon we'll have pure face datasets
for both of our characters.
Now we want to train our model on this
Dataset so it learns to encode these
faces,
meaning tell them apart from one another.
There are a bunch of measurements that
we could take of a face to try and tell
what it looks like. Ear size
knows length, et Cetera,
but it turns out that it's better to
have our algorithm learn these things for
itself.
Convolutional neural networks have been
shown to offer really great performance
in learning to classify faces.
It's a neural network with
its own distinct set of
operations like convolutions
and pooling.
These operations amount to simple
matrix math applied to an input image.
The output being a classification,
but we don't simply want
to classify an image.
We want to learn a representation of both
faces and somehow morph face a to look
like face B in the most
realistic way possible.
So what we'll use is an auto encoder.
This is a convolutional network that
tries to reconstruct the input image.
This lets it learn a lower dimensional
representation of the input image,
which will later use to swap basis.
Specifically deep fakes uses one encoder
and two decoders during training.
It actually trains two networks.
Both the networks share an encoder but
have different decoders on Incode or
transforms an image into a base vector.
This is a set of numbers which identify
the important features of the face.
The decoder transforms that
vector back to an image.
There is an error function which measures
how good the transformation was and
the model tries to lower the
overall error during training.
The first network is only trained on
image a and the second network is only
trained on image be the encoder learns
how to convert an image into a face
vector decoder a learns how to convert
a base factor to image a and code or B,
wanting to try to convert
a base factor to image B.
So during training we're feeding
both images to the same encoder,
but using two different decoders for each.
After the network is done training,
we can feed it a video.
A video is simply a collection
of image frames, one by one.
We'll first crop out the target
face from the video frame,
then perform a face swap on it.
That means feeding image a to the encoder,
creating a base vector,
then feeding it to decoder,
be resulting in a face that looks like B,
which we can then overlay
onto the original frame.
Then we can concatenate all of those
images together and watch the video result
for ourselves soon.
This technology will get more realistic
and more accessible and anyone will be
able to make it look like you are doing
something you never really did via
video, which could be degrading.
But this can also be a good thing.
Anyone will be able to make all sorts
of entertaining content that wouldn't be
possible before easily.
It's gonna get harder to
distinguish what's real and
what's fake as AI improves.
And we'll need to work on
more deterministic algorithms
that offer computational
proofs to help us trust sources more.
Enter blockchain and cryptography.
Three things to remember from this video.
We can use open CV to perform facial
detection using the histogram of oriented
gradients.
Approach convolutional networks can learn
features from images and auto encoders
can encode representations that we can
later use to more for one image into
another. Last week's coding
challenge. Winner is Ivan [inaudible],
who used an auto encoder to convert
DNA sequences into RNA sequences.
This is such a cool
application. Great job, Ivan.
And the runner up is
param deep sing Oberoi,
who created a well documented auto
encoder on the M and ist Dataset.
You already know what this week's
coding challenge is. Generate a face,
swap yourself and post a link to your
github repo in the youtube comments and
winners will be announced next week.
Please subscribe for more
programming videos. And for now,
I've got to prepare myself to get
baseball, so thanks for watching.